en France la vipère c'est le seul
reptile venimeux en liberté une fois sur
deux la bestiole vous mord sans injecter
de venin c'est ce qu'on appelle une
morsure blanche mais parfois l'animal
injecte son venin et les premiers signes
apparaissent environ une demi-heure
après la mort sur fait mal voir très mal
elle se met à gonfler et parallèlement
le rythme cardiaque s'accélère on
ressent des nausées qui peuvent aller
jusqu'au vomissement et des diarrhées
apparaissent appeler le SAMU au 15 parce
qu'il va falloir aller à l'hôpital pour
une surveillance voir pour injecter un
antivenin pour assurer la personne qui a
été mordu lui demander de s'allonger et
de rester calme pour ralentir la
diffusion du venin enlevez tout ce qui
entoure le membre mordus ça va gonfler
vaut mieux éviter que ça serre et faites
un pansement il faut que le bandage par
de la racine du membre jusqu'à son
extrémité que vous puissiez passer un
doigt entre la bande et la peau il faut
pas faire de garrot immobiliser le
membre et mettez-le un peu en l'air pour
limiter le gonflement et donc pour ce
qui est d'aspirer le venin l'aspivenin
pour commencer c'est une espèce de
grosse seringue avec une ventouse au
bout qu'on applique sur les piqûres mais
les vipères injectent le leur beaucoup
trop loin sous la peau pour que ce soit
efficace donc ça marche pas et du coup
sucer la plaie et ben ça marche pas non
plus